it's important that you become rather
skeptical of your first intuitions
because they're often very misleading
um just as every boy thinks his father
is the strongest man in the world
and then when he grows up into adulthood
he realizes
his father was not even close to being
the strongest man in the world it's not
because
of anything other than an experience to
a boy his father seems overwhelmingly
strong he literally can't even imagine
anyone else being stronger than that so
naively he thinks his father is the
strongest man in the world so too in our
relationship with animals
when we look at a Silverback Gorilla it
just looks overwhelmingly strong to us
to a degree which is almost absurd like
um
you picture the greatest combat athletes
that Humanity has ever produced the
prime Mike Tyson Gordon Ryan for
grappling
they would literally be torn limb from
limb by an angry gorilla it wouldn't
even be remotely competitive and so
there's a sense in which we look at them
in awe because of what they could do to
us
but that can be very misleading and just
as a boy
looks at his father as like the Pinnacle
of strength you can't necessarily from a
position of inexperience and weakness
look at a given animal and say oh that
must be the toughest animal in the
animal kingdom there's levels to this
game and
um I think we can point out that the
gorilla ultimately would be pretty low
on those levels
pushed back to this analysis because the
data we don't have much data on this we
don't have we actually have slightly
more than you think I believe oh boy
well it's anecdotal I feel like it's out
of context so these species don't use
this is not MMA they don't do
inter-species fighting often
yeah but there are some ways of looking
at this which can take this already
interesting question and make it a lot
more interesting
um
first we've seen that intuitions aren't
to be trusted so if intuitions aren't to
be trusted or what is to be trusted here
well I've always believed that there are
three
General
elements that determine
what level of success or failure anyone
will experience in combat and this is
true both for individuals and for groups
and even all the way out to Nations
um
the first is what are your skills the
second is what are your physical and
mental attributes so skills attributes
those are the two primary ones and
there's a third
which is your experience in using those
skills and attributes and real world
scenarios okay so whenever two we'll
start with two humans when two humans
get into a fight ask yourself what is
their skill set
what are their physical and mental
attributes and what is their experience
and using those in real world
applications and that will give you your
first
look at uh okay who's going to be the
more successful
um
then in addition to those
three General elements there's also four
more specific elements
what is the ability
of the combatants to initiate combat
because initiation is a big deal in
fighting the one who sees the enemy
first and can create Ambush conditions
or
initiate compact combat in an area or a
Terrain which is favorable to them this
is huge in determining the uh the
outcome of battles
second
not only is initiation important but
disengagement is important a lot of
battles don't go according to plan and
so your ability to disengage at will and
break off and away from a battle is key
to success so initiation and
disengagement are big
the third big element
what is your ability to end a fight
okay do you have an efficient method of
ending conflict
without that
the conflict could go on to a point
where you no longer have the ability to
uh to continue it if you have some
succinct method of finishing this is
huge in combat and determining winner or
loser so both from a winning and a
losing position so if you don't have one
there's a high much higher chance you'll
lose but if you have an ability to
finish an opponent in the conflict uh
reliably this is very very important in
determining success or failure
and third is your ability to endure a
conflict longer than the person you're
you're engaged in okay so engage with
sorry and so you get these four more
specific elements now do you have the
ability to initiate contact at will do
you have the ability to break contact
and disengage at will
do you have the ability to finish your
opponent efficiently and do you have the
ability to endure longer than your
opponent does if you have all four of
those
that's huge for for combat that probably
applies to human on human everything
military conflict everything even all
the way up to Nations
um
also ask yourself
what are the most efficient
methods of combat
across the globe across all species all
times
etc etc and you'll see that ultimately
they always come down to
three things
the first is concentration of force
okay one of the most successful
combat strategies of all time is the
ability to take
concentrated Force against the zone of
weakness in your opponent and if you can
do this
you will often break through to a point
of vulnerability attack that
vulnerability in a way where your
opponent cannot respond and cannot
recover from that vulnerable point being
broken do a high amount of damage with
Precision yes so this is one of the
great combat strategies in across the
animal kingdom across human history Etc
the second would be Ambush tactics
if you can Ambush an opponent with the
element of surprise this is huge for
success in combat they're almost all of
the truly successful Predators on this
planet are Ambush Predators
the ability to get off to a good start
in a way where opponents simply can't
recover is huge for combat are we
allowing ambush in our discussion
because humans would call this cheating
perhaps yes we would and
humans are pretty damn good at it too so
um uh and then the third is endurance
okay some uh
[Music]
species some people uh humans actually
are pretty good at this
um use endurance as a weapon and they
simply wear an opponent down over time
and break them and internationally this
can be done economically
um through numbers etc etc and uh and
you can destroy someone with just sheer
endurance yeah a lot of words throughout
human history has been Siege Warfare
yeah and so when you ask yourself okay
which one of these animals are going to
uh be the most successful in combat ask
yourself well there's these three
Elements which tend to determine
Successful Failure and warfare
um which animals exhibit these three
principles the best and we'll discuss
this
but as far as um
uh generalities go uh whenever you ask a
question who will win between a and b
ask yourself
in terms of the light of what we've just
discussed
what is their skill set
what are the attributes both mental and
physical what is their experience in
utilizing these in real world situations
and then the four uh more technical
elements who gets to initiate contact
can you break off contact at any given
time uh what is your endurance can you
keep going uh longer than your opponent
does so a skill set I wonder if a big
component of that of how much practice
there is off off the battle